حتى ولو لم تكن تعرف اسمه او لا يمكنك
تمييز ملامحه فحت ما بتعرف مقطوعه موسيقيه
او اكثر من اعماله
العديد من روائع موسيقى افلام هوليود كان
ورائها هالزمر الموسيقار الالماني
الاسطوري احد اشهر منتجيه ومؤلف في موسيقى
الافلام التصويريه في العالم يعود له
الفضل في تاليف موسيقى لاكثر
فيلما على مدار 40 عاما حقق بفضلها جائزتي
اوسكار كما يملك ثلاث جوائز اخرى من
مسابقه جولدن
[موسيقى]
ترشح على الزمر لجائزه اوسكار في 11
مناسبه فاذا منها بجائزتين اول اوسكار
حققه زمر كان عبره فلميشن ذا لاين كينج
عام
1995 وكان ثاني ترشيحات الاوسكار بعد فيلم
بين مان قبل هذه سته اعوام وبين اول
والثاني اوسكار 27 عاما حيث تلقى جائزته
الثانيه خلال مسابقه العام الماضي
لكن فيما بينهما مسيره موسيقيه تناولت
كافه المشاعر هو الرجل الذي يقف وراء
معزوفه فيلم جلاديتر الذي يعد احد اهم
الافلام في تاريخ السينما العالميه زلمه
بسماته الابداعيه على اعمال كريستوفر
نولان ايضا
فقدم الجمال والغضب والاثاره عبر ذا دعك
نايت او انترستلر وادن كيك وبالطبع انسبشن
خلال العام الماضي على انك موسوعه جينيس
الارقام القياسيه ان هانز من هو المؤلف
الموسيقي المتصدر للافلام صاحبه اعلى
الايرادات في شباك التذاكر العالم حيث
وصلت ارادته الافلام التي عمل فيها الى 27
مليار دولار حتى 2019